one for coming to the transcriptomics
orientation if you guys have been to any
other orientations whether that be for
the other training modules or
um for the overall informational um
session that was last week this will be
a bit of a review for the first about 15
minutes or so
so i do want to start off by thanking
both lsu biomed which is the division of
biotechnical and molecular medicine at
lsu
which comprises a variety of cores that
are available for their own
subspecialties
as well as lbrn which is the louisiana
biomedical research network they are the
two groups that are funding
the training modules this semester
uh just to address a quick question will
there be any participation certificate
for today's webinar uh no this is just
an orientation information an
informational session um
so there are three training modules that
are being offered this semester today
we're gonna be talking about the
transcriptomics
first off let me emphasize some of the
things about the training modules first
off they're entirely asynchronous you
can participate them in them at any of
your available schedules
if something doesn't work out for you
you can always come back and watch
recorded lectures you can access the
asynchronous courses online at any time
this is really designed to fit within
our busy schedules as researchers or as
scientists um however you're not going
to be left on your own the goal of this
training module um is to help you
through the process to learn more about
transfer genomics whether that be single
cell or bulk um and so there's a variety
of mentors
that will be available to you
to help you through this process so
you're going to primarily interact with
these mentors through the lectures so if
you participate in the lectures when
they're given live you'll be able to ask
questions directly there however if you
aren't able to do so because of your
schedule there are a variety of other
ways to reach out to these mentors one
of which is online chat so there's
several methods that we'll talk about
later on
about how you can reach out to these
mentors if you run into any issues or
just have a curiosity question and
they'll be able to assist you
additionally if you complete
these training modules you will receive
a certificate of completion and it's
going to be associated with what
institution you're from so if you're
associated directly with lsu you'll
receive a certificate that
is customized to lsu and is going to be
signed by dr gus casoulis if you are
with lbrn you are likely to be
receiving a certificate customized lbrn
signed by the bioinformatics core lead
at lbrn which is dr chris taylor
and if you're out if you're outside
either of those two networks you're
going to receive a certificate of
completion from the omics logic team
themselves
so there's going to be three primary
ways that you're going to participate in
this program
the first one is if you haven't already
done so please go over to
learn.omicslogic.com
and register because the omics omixlogic
portal is your primary way of accessing
the information you will need to access
for this training module it's how you're
going to be enrolled in the the course
uh as well as how to access your
asynchronous courses so if you haven't
done this already and you're still
interested in joining make sure you do
that right away
most of you probably already have um so
you'll be able to we'll walk through
some of the syllabus stuff on the
mxlogic portal in a little bit
but another platform that you will gain
access to if you've already registered
on mx logic it should automatically give
you a t bio info platform
access as well this platform is designed
for individuals to take omics data
whether that be in whatever form you're
working with it in and work through a
essentially a flow chart or a pipeline
as it's referred to as
to process that data using the different
analysis techniques that you'll learn
about during this training module so you
don't have to go and encode all of that
information yourself the pipeline will
help you do that
additionally you will have some
experience or interaction with code the
coding playground which is essentially
designed as an online
coding environment prepared for you so
you can practice coding without having
to establish a coding playground on your
own computer which can be somewhat
difficult for individuals that aren't
experienced with the process
so those are the three things you're
going to be focusing on and some of the
benefits of this training module
this is going to be an advanced training
module that means there's an expectation
that you fully understand biological and
computational verbiage or at least the
large majority of the verbiage you'll
see you're gonna you're expected to have
some statistical experience you don't
have to be a statistician but you should
have the understanding of some of the
basic concepts um you may have some
coding experience with either r or
python most likely are for biologists
but not always the case
as well as you should have some
understanding of next generation
sequencing and how it works and if you
don't understand it fully that's okay
because the the training module will go
through that
some of these processes for you
that being said today's the orientation
session for this training module you
should already have access if you've
registered in advance if you don't
please reach out to one of us so that we
can get you enrolled
now what exactly is this training module
focused on
this training module is designed to show
you how to perform transcriptomic data
analysis and data visualization many of
us have already seen how this data is
visualized through papers and other
omics related studies that we've read
this training module is designed to show
you some of the behind the scenes stuff
that happens to get to that point with
your data you're going to cover a lot of
different topics such as machine
learning for expression data some data
analysis exploratory data analysis
methods as well as here's an example of
multivariate analysis they'll be
discussing some next gen sequencing
processing for gene expression data and
here's some of the data mining
classification information you'll cover
as well as how to biologically interpret
uh that data which many of us have
probably seen something similar to
pathway analysis or downstream analysis
uh while we go through our biological
related papers
so you're also going to have the
opportunity to complete your own
independent transcriptomic project
during this training module
so
that if you have your own data you can
actually incorporate it here
if not there is still a variety of
publicly available data that pine bio
has actually provided for this course
for this training module to help you
through it
and like i mentioned you will learn how
to identify analyze and visualize all
the appropriate data for transparent
data
so
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
here this is the finalized syllabus for
the training module you can access this
online as well um if you go to the link
that was just provided
in the chat
and you can go through the the actual
subtopics that are in each lecture if
you're curious
this is some of the things they're going
to be covered in this course just to
kind of summarize you're going to have a
variety of asynchronous courses and
tutorials to help you through the
process you'll have access to mentor
support you'll have methods explained to
you how are they performed why are they
performed what is the benefit what are
what are the pros and cons of using that
particular analysis
you're going to have multi-omics ai
guided instructions this is an image
here of the pipeline that i was
discussing on the tbio platform you'll
learn what each one of these particular
subsets
is involved with and why it's performed
how it's performed etc
you'll get to analyze gene expression
data
you'll learn some
some of the logic behind data science
which many of our us as biologists may
not be exposed to on a regular basis you
also have some biomedical data exposure
as well as that project that i uh
mentioned to you and then if you choose
to do so you should be able to then take
that project at the end of this training
module and present it
at a conference of your choice and i'll
talk about one of those particular
conferences here in a second
so if you're part of lsu or lbrn there
are some additional resources available
to you that could be beneficial outside
of this training module so
if you're in the network there's a lsu
gene lab which lsu gene lab is a sub
core in the biomed program it's
available to both lsu and lbrn labs and
it provides a variety of both
consultation and experimental services
so if you don't know how to perform
perform a variety of experiments
yourself
thea in the gene lab would be an
excellent person to reach out to to see
if she could perform that for you at an
affordable price some of those process
some of those services i've listed here
which include sequencing and next-gen
sequencing techniques multiplex protein
analysis and more now this is just a
subset if you're curious you can go to
their website uh after the lecture
additionally
if you are associated with the lbrn or
an lbrn associated institution
there's the bioinformatics biostatistics
and computational biology core which is
designed to provide consulting
mentorship and training in the field of
data science and bioinformatics
primarily directed to faculty or pis
additionally like i mentioned that
conference and that that potential to
present your project there is the annual
lbrn conference um on computational
biology and bioinformatics this is
usually held around april um but it's
focused on the springtime so that's not
necessarily a solid date just keep a
look out for more information about that
if you're interested
additionally if you would like to
continue your knowledge on
bioinformatics there is a master's
program available at lsu health in new
orleans
so you can look into that if you want to
continue learning about this
if you're a faculty or you're a pi
member and you're interested about
having these programs offered at your
institution you can reach out to ilya
brodsky who is the ceo of pine biotech
at ilia
pine.bio
and he will have more information about
what
programs they offer
if you are interested
so i'm going to stop here for any
questions before i show you guys a
little bit about the omixlogic portal
and hand it off
before i hand it off to the pine
biomentors
one question why the need for single uh
and
or bulk transparency not just
transactions um so ilia will actually
get into that a little bit into his
portion of the discussion which will
happen in a little bit i'll give you
more details about uh the benefits of
both and what's going to be covered in
the lecture
um are there any other non-lsu students
here uh yes there's a variety of non-lsu
students in the chat right now um
this program is totally online
the only issue is uh if you're not lsu
or lbrm associated you're not going to
have this available to you for free
you'll have to fund it yourself
okay so
that being said i'm going to go ahead
and stop sharing like this screen for a
second and i'm going to show you guys a
little bit about
the um
omixlogic portal
okay
so if you guys like i said haven't
already done this please go to omixlogic
the oxology portal where you'll be able
to
uh learn.mxlogic.com
um basically it'll take you to this
screen here
what you can do if you're interested um
you could register entirely for free
this is not going to be directly linked
to the program when you register this is
just to give you access to the portal so
if you're curious you can hit register
for free
which will take you to a sign in or sign
up
page where if you have an account you
can just sign in but if you don't have
an account you can sign up by clicking
one additional button and i'll show you
here once that loads
so if you haven't made an account you
just have to click on create an account
here and this box will expand and allow
you to enter some information like your
name
the email address and your new password
that you'd like to use because i've
already made an account i'm not going to
do that i'm going to stay here let me
sign in page
i'm going to go ahead and sign in
it'll take you to a page like this
my recommendation for the quickest way
to access everything that you that you
would be uh involved in is to go to your
profile by clicking on the welcome back
where your email should pop up
and it'll take you to this page
so if you're already in a program and
you're already enrolled in a program
you'll be able to see that program down
here in the badges section so for this
particular program you should see this
badge that says transcriptomics and you
can click on that i'll go ahead and open
it as a new tab because we'll go to that
in a moment
but this will open your syllabus your
access to all of the information that
the program is intended to guide you
through etc you can also find your
program under the programs tab over here
if you click on this
you should see access to biomed tran
vulcan single cell transcriptomics
down here
now once you get into this and you start
taking some of the asynchronous courses
the courses that you have started or
have you taken even if it's only partial
or like a portion of a first lesson it
will then show up under the courses tab
so you'll be able to go to this and
quickly access any of the courses that
you're currently working on
such as see i've completed python course
one
introduction to bioinformatics and i'm
mostly done with the bio ml course so if
you're curious about how to find a
course you've already started you can go
here
you will also once you complete a course
receive a certificate
and this will be similar to the
certificate you'll receive once you
complete the entirety of the program
it'll look something similar to this so
if you're an outside individual
individual it'll look very similar to
this it'll say that you've completed the
program
and it'll be signed by an individual
from pine biotech or the omixlogic team
but like i said if you're from lsu or
lbrn it will look slightly different
where it'll be customized for your
institution and it will be signed by a
different individual from that
institution
now
what now what i want to show you really
quickly is the syllabus so if you click
on this particular link it'll open a
page that looks like this if you don't
if you're not enrolled in this
particular program it will look a little
different your name will not pop up here
so if that doesn't happen and you know
you're supposed to be enrolled please
contact one of us
however if you are enrolled it'll look
like this it'll show your point system
your name etc
and you can scroll down here to find the
syllabus
now
once you complete the lecture and all of
the information associated here these
online resources
um
you'll be able to click on complete
session and as you go through you'll see
that each week a different session will
become available for you to complete
once you've completed all of the
sessions which will go through december
for this particular training module
you'll be able to complete all of the
sessions and you'll receive your
certificate
each one of these
lectures is associated with a live
lecture which will be recorded if you're
not able to get to that as well as these
associated online resources which you
can click on and it'll take you to
additional learning information that you
should go through for each particular
lecture
i will address what's the difference
between the course from
i believe you mean lsu so there's no
actual difference between the content
between lsu lbrn or outside individuals
it just has to do with how you're going
about registering and how you have to
find the program
so that being said i'm going to go ahead
and stop sharing and i'm going to hand
off
the lecture to ilia at amelia brosky the
ceo of pine biotic
thank you